[Music]
are you putting your greasy fingers all
over your keyboard and screen ever find
a snack in between those keys thank you
don't have dirt think again do you just
turn to household cleaning supplies to
clean up the mess
don't instead you should try my
revolutionary gadget cleaning program
okay
I'm not the ShamWow guy but your gadgets
are gross so here's my advice for
cleaning your phone tablet and computer
no monthly installments completely free
though you do have to buy some cleaning
supplies first before you even roll up
your sleeves and put on the gloves
unplug your devices and power them off
now let's begin with removing the
fingerprints and other schmutz from the
screen stay away from wind acts soft
scrub and any other cleaning supplies
that have ammonia or are abrasive and
don't use paper towels they'll leave
lint scratches or big streaks instead
buy a microfiber cloth like this one
from iclear that has a terry cloth feel
the flatter ones like this one called
the eye cloth don't absorb liquids as
well
microfiber alone will clean the screen
but not as well as dampening it with
some water or some screen cleaners don't
ever apply the spray directly to the
screen now what spray to use is the big
question now there are lots of screen
cleaning solutions and I tested a lot of
them and they work really well they
leave no streaks on the screen but I
found that a homemade solution of water
and a bit of isopropyl alcohol did just
as well the catch there is is that you
have to put it in a misting spray bottle
to evenly apply it to the cloth of the
commercial cleaners I did like I clears
kit the best because of the included
microfiber cloth and the solution
doesn't have a strong of an odor as the
others you can also use these to clean
the exterior of your phone computer or
tablet I prefer to eye clear and zag
though to the water-based solutions they
were just easier to clean off the
surfaces when you get to cleaning
remember to clean around the trackpad
and other small areas you might not see
the dirt in regular light but this UV
light reveals all now it's time to talk
about your chrome covered oily mess of a
keyboard
my first revolutionary trick tipping it
over then a can of compressed air is
still the best way to get the [ __ ] out
of the tighter areas of your keyboard
I did try more eco-friendly and
economical options but this Canlas
electronic option didn't have as much
power to blow away those stubborn little
pieces of dirt and this battery-powered
vacuum was a total wimp now grab that
damp microfiber cloth again and wash
down those keys
I also liked this $5 Good Grips
electronic cleaning brush it's got a
nice little brush here on the end and
you can sweep through the keys and it's
good for getting into the ports though
you can pretty much also use a
toothbrush so there you have it a good
microfiber terry cloth and some water
and a misting spray bottle will go a
long way and i clear solution even just
for getting that microfiber cloth is
probably a worthy investment and when it
comes to cleaning that keyboard don't
forget the canned air and a small brush